the legend of sleepy hollow was popular
enough nearly a hundred years ago for
one of hollywood's biggest stars at the
time will rogers you take a stab at
bringing the ghost story to the big
screen
it was first published 200 years ago by
washington irving considered by many to
be the father of the american short
story
sleepy hollow may be america's all-time
great ghost story
and two centuries later is still linked
forever to halloween
today we visit the history of this
classic tale in the spot where it all
began
most people passing by these days don't
even know it's there
but 25 miles north of new york city in a
place overlooking the hudson river
the legend of the headless horseman took
off
i can't think of a more iconic halloween
character than the headless horseman
he really is the one he's kind of the
original american ghost story
and he's he's our arch villain elizabeth
bradley is an author
an expert on the man who first told of
the horseman 200 years ago
washington irving he wrote here he did
and he wrote in that room right there
that was his study
we spoke to bradley at irving's famed
sunny side estate
the stories he wrote were witty
mischievous anarchic and they have
really formed the foundation for
so much of of american literature
mischievous is a good word for it
definitely definitely set shortly after
the american revolution
irving's the legend of sleepy hollow
unspools the story of ichabod crane
an oddball outsider who arrives in town
and pursues a beautiful young woman
katrina van tassel he is then himself
pursued by a local phantom known
as the headless horseman as legend goes
the horseman was a hessian soldier
who lost his head to a cannonball while
fighting for the british
he was buried but it said he rises from
his grave every night
in search of his missing skull the
original tale
just 24 pages long seems to grow more
famous
each year the legend of sleepy hollow
was popular when it was first published
but it was
not the totemic story that we know it
today nobody had heard of the headless
horseman
he the headless horseman was irving's
really to invent in
in the forum in which it took in that
story
the story has spawned countless
adaptations most notably disney's
1949 classic the adventures of ichabod
and mr
toad
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and the 1999 tim burton film sleepy
hollow starring johnny depp
[Music]
when people revisit the legend of sleepy
hollow today what should they think
i think they should take the time to
appreciate the imagery and the way in
which it's inspired
all of the adaptations there is
something about the mystery
and the way in which irving describes
the landscape as being one of contagion
that i think really describes our own
obsession with halloween today
that contagion takes on an even more
eerie relevance these days
guess what else was happening a little
more than 200 years ago
washington irving fled a pandemic he did
he did he came to this region first as a
teenager
and the reason he did so is because new
york was experiencing an epidemic of
yellow fever
so people trying to get out of a major
city
into the suburbs very much as they are
today irving's sunny side is still open
to visitors
but because of our current pandemic no
one is allowed inside
or his writing desk and the bedroom
where he died in 1859 have been
preserved
people of all ages come to hear the
stories about the legend
and its author whose penchant for
mischief is on full display
1656 is just a date that irving
put up for the fun of it you know this
is a little touch of the ways in which
irving
liked to play with ideas of authenticity
with the notion of history being fixed
so people walk by this and say 1656 and
like what does that mean they think that
the house as
we see it today must have all been built
in 1656 and i think irving would have
loved that
which but it's not true at all it's not
true no there would have been a very
small
farmhouse here not far away from the
house
the graveyard at the old dutch church
where the horseman is said to roam
is also a tourist attraction today so he
just hangs out here
that is what they say we can come back
after dark
irving is buried in the adjacent sleepy
hollow cemetery
part of what makes this region feel so
charmed and and possibly haunted is that
not only is his home here but his
gravesite is here and they're both
accessible to
anyone who wants to come and see them
the cemetery even features a bridge
not unlike one that figures prominently
in the legend
people know it as the horsemen they know
it they insist this must be the bridge
you know at the base of this bridge is
where they were meant to have found a
shattered pumpkin
and the saddle of the horseycabad road
and no ichabod and it was never seen
again
at least on the pages of irving's story
what's your favorite version
of the story i'd say irving's because
there's so much magic in it and there's
so much detail
and mystery to be mined and there's a
lot of comedy too that people tend to
lose sight of
but the ending in irving's version
remains nebulous
yes it's purposefully vague i think and
that's part of irving's genius that
means that the headless horseman then
could still be oh yes out here
absolutely he's
he's ageless so yeah just you know don't
look behind you
shout out to seth fox his first producer
piece there
he did it he did a great job with a
couple other notes north terrytown
actually renamed itself a town in new
york
to sleepy hollow 25 years ago to
capitalize
on the story's fame which is interesting
and the interesting thing about
the the story in general the first 24
pages it's so
pliable that there's a version you can
find for kids adults i mean
tim burton's sleepy hollow not for kids
not for kids my favorite i love that i
just love tim burton's version
it's a very good movie but not for kids
ichabod and mr toad
is for kids totally for kids right